có hỏi đã tính nhạm vô chơi.
Đứng nói chờ
bởi vì ở ăn thấy cái nhiều người
cái thời gian làm phim
khó hợp với dạm lần
lúc đó là mình không thể nào
mà wafim được nếu mình không có tình
đi mô phim được ở phim
mình có phong tình chuyển phim
qua qua bằng
em mình điểm
ra mình cũng không xác tình muốn phòng dưỡng để dựng phí lâu
phải cách phim
để mình phải bướng phòng thu
mình cho nên là phí mà
là phải sinh mà
mà
cho còn hay mùi đồ
em để dạm lời chạm
lái xe lên hòa lực buổi
dầu
dìn mô được bằng công phim
quay được các bà hà phúc
tổng mùi bả ý đồ
mô được cái cụm nữa dạm
mọi người mấy
quay bà phúc
ở trên lần
đồ của dân xa số
có pháng gì lại người biệt
mình làm phí lời
nhưng mà lúc mùi xác lời
hòa mất cối được
phải cảm gà đại
lãi xem, viên nhiều mà hoa lên gửi đến chỗ hước đó
lãi xe dài, đời gầnؤng.
V onze giá lãi mước cho lãi.
Vậy cho nữa dài, ra vui, ra vui.
Đói, mấy còi, mấy biết mình.
2 tụp cửa quay giống dì.
Mà có 2, dưới này.
Gẫm i giờ mà có gì台 lần hoi, lần phía xam esu quay.
2 gà ngoài đi ngôi lãi quay.
Với, nó như ngôi ít thôi, chở.
Lần phía mở, lần phía nó.
Lần phía nó.
Nó, sông rối.
Để sau phát ngồi đó đã ở đây là thế nào không có lập phím được
Mặc rất là chào chừng nào cho ông tất cả kêu hỏi lưng
Này chồng quý mình